[Música]
bienvenidos al debate de france 24 soy
santiago lópez gonzález las opciones
para la oposición en venezuela son cada
vez menos sobre todo después de que el
chavismo recuperará el control de la
asamblea nacional en unas elecciones
parlamentarias marcadas por la masiva
abstención la falta de participación
precisamente de los partidos de la
oposición y la falta del reconocimiento
internacional miren ustedes en la
siguiente gráfica eeuu los países del
grupo de lima y también los países de la
unión europea indicaron que no reconocen
estos comicios como democráticos por lo
tanto no van a reconocer su resultado
mientras que rusia y cuba que son países
aliados de nicolás maduro por su parte
aplaudieron este resultado de estos
comicios del fin de semana pasado méxico
y argentina que son países importantes
en la región de américa latina aún no se
han pronunciado sobre los resultados de
estas elecciones
de esta forma el oficialismo gana
entonces mayor control político pero el
gobierno de nicolás maduro hace frente a
una aguda crisis económica social y
también sanitaria por la pandemia del
cob y 19 que parece no tocar fondo así
se adjudicó el triunfo en estos comicios
nicolás maduró escuchemos hemos cumplido
con la constitución hemos cumplido con
esta constitución cinco años después
tengo que salir a decir tenemos una
nueva asamblea nacional producto del
voto popular el pueblo elegido a sus
nuevos diputados a sus nuevas diputadas
y hemos tenido una tremenda y gigantesca
victoria electoral el próximo 5 de enero
de 2021 será instaurada esta nueva
asamblea nacional que hasta ahora ha
sido liderada por juan guaidó quien a su
vez es reconocido también como
presidente interino de venezuela y es
reconocido por 50 países alrededor del
mundo quien indicó también que este
proceso electoral fue totalmente
fraudulento estas fueron sus palabras
escuchemos él
y ha sido consumado y el rechazo
mayoritario del pueblo de venezuela ha
sido evidente solo hacen fraude en los
que le temen al pueblo y maduro y su
régimen perdió todo el apoyo popular que
sucederá entonces con juan guaidó a
partir del 5 de enero cuál será su
futuro qué opciones tiene entonces la
dividida oposición venezolana que hará
la comunidad internacional qué harán los
líderes opositores que están en el
exilio y qué hará el gobierno para
mantener a flote el país para analizar y
conocer más detalles sobre este tema
saludamos a jaime nogales ella es
analista abogada y especialista en
derecho procesal con experiencia también
en temas electorales y también es
integrante de varias iniciativas de
diálogo y de la despolarización en
venezuela ya está en la ciudad de
caracas y también está con nosotros
jesús silva analista y doctor en derecho
constitucional también se une a esta
conversación desde la ciudad de caracas
la capital venezolana le desean recuerdo
que ustedes también son parte de este
debate son parte de esta conversación
pueden dejar las preguntas los
comentarios en las redes sociales en los
recuerdo estamos en facebook y también
nos encuentran en instagram
y en twitter como france24
guión al piso s sant y luego vi cuenta
personal y la etiqueta es numeral el
debate efe 24 pues tenemos el tema
tenemos el contexto y ya tienen ustedes
las coordenadas en las redes sociales
para que comiencen a dejar sus
comentarios y quiero entonces
preguntarle a amy en las ciudades de
caracas cuál puede ser con este panorama
que hemos explicado el proceder que
tenga la oposición a partir de este
momento cómo van a ajustar entonces las
cartas que tengan bajo la manga de cara
a lo que se viene para el 5 de enero
bueno la oposición está frente a un reto
muy importante el primer reto es asumir
el desastre político asumir
las fallas en la estrategia y empezar a
planificar en función de la realidad
los próximos tres años serán un
horizonte electoral hay que enfrentar
las elecciones de alcaldes y
gobernadores
y alcaldes en 2009 22 gobernadores 2021
y presidenciales en 2023
si la oposición no logra ajustar las
expectativas volverá a ser coherente y
reconectar con la población y lo más
probable es que ni siquiera alcancen los
votos para un evento presidencial y
jesús cuál es su perspectiva que puede
hacer la oposición de aquí en adelante
primer lugar tenemos que aclarar que hay
dos lados de la oposición hay una
oposición que participó en las
elecciones parlamentarias
fueron legales que fueron legítimas que
fueron transparentes y que obtuvo cerca
de un 17 18 por ciento de los votos y va
a tener un conjunto de diputados en la
asamblea nacional haciendo el trabajo
que se hace en democracia debatir opinar
vivir la democracia por otro lado hay
una pequeña oposición que no tiene votos
que no puede adjudicarse la abstención a
su favor porque eso sería un disparate y
esa pequeña oposición encabezada por
juan guaidó que no es una figura popular
dentro de la oposición venezolana
seguirá solicitando apoyo económico de
eeuu seguirán pidiéndole de arco viva
militares venezolanos para que se
revelen y es una agenda del fracaso es
una agenda que tiene 2 años
implementándose y que no ha servido para
que este señor mayor y que no acompañan
esa minoría que puedan avanzar en la
toma del poder político el único saldo
que le deja cuando a venezuela
es el robo de nuestras empresas
petroleras en el exterior me refiero a 5
en eeuu que le pertenece a venezuela
pero fue robada por la colaboración de
wide o a monómeros que le pertenece a
venezuela y se encuentra en colombia y
fue robada con la colaboración de wide o
entonces hay dos oposiciones una pequeña
sin votos que depende de eeuu y los
países aliados eeuu como una posición
política ataca venezuela difama
venezuela bloquea venezuela y por ende
rendirá venezuela por la vía de la
asfixia económica y una gran oposición
que obtuvo más de un millón de votos y
que está haciendo vida democrática en
venezuela entonces el resumen del 6 de
diciembre es la muerte política de
huairou es un personaje despreciado en
decir jesús y el triunfo de la
democracia porque el porcentaje de votos
que se obtuvo en venezuela en estas
elecciones legislativas está dentro
estándar internacional vamos a comparar
colombia jesús vamos a comparar eeuu
vamos a comparar países de la unión
europea el porcentaje es legítimo es
válido y tiene que ser reconocido tarde
o temprano por eeuu y estos países que
acompañan ese criterio de presionar y de
acorralar a venezuela y esa agenda de
hostilidad diplomática no va a ser le
pido por favor que sea más concreto en
sus respuestas y no se me extienda mucho
porque tengo tengo varios temas para
abarcar el programa es muy corto sigo
con ustedes jesús y quiero precisamente
preguntarle por la otra cara de la
moneda ya hablábamos de la oposición
ahora veamos el oficialismo qué pasos va
a dar entonces ahora el oficialismo
desde su perspectiva teniendo en cuenta
esta falta de reconocimiento
internacional de estas elecciones esta
falta de reconocimiento por parte de
organismos internacionales y una
asamblea nacional que se va a instaurar
a partir del 5 de enero que tal parece
que para la comunidad internacional como
ya lo dijimos no va a tener validez y va
a generar un conflicto a nivel
internacional para venezuela y para la
política venezolana como
entonces ahí el panorama
muy fácil mi estimado amigo y te hablo
como profesor de estudios
internacionales aquí en venezuela
sencillamente la comunidad internacional
está compuesta por cerca de 200 países
50 encabezados por eeuu no reconocen las
instituciones venezolanas y unos 150 si
nos reconocen seguiremos haciendo
negocios internacionales con los países
que reconocen a venezuela la vida
diplomática de la república va a
continuar estando temprana eeuu y los
países que obedecen su política
injerencista deberán comprender que esta
fórmula del presidente paralelo no
funcionó con baidu y que desconocer la
sangre nacional electa por el pueblo
tampoco va a funcionar tiene que ver un
diálogo tiene que ver diplomacia tiene
que venir entendimiento entre los países
y su opinión en mí también allá en la
ciudad de caracas cuál va a ser entonces
esos pasos a seguir por parte del
oficialismo para hacer que la comunidad
internacional entonces reconozca estos
estos comicios parlamentarios o por lo
menos generan un acercamiento entre los
venezolanos porque hubo una alta
abstención así en este país en estas
elecciones mira yo creo que estamos
viviendo la parte 2 de una novela en el
2005 la oposición se retiró el mmr el
movimiento quinta república que en ese
momento era la fuerza política que
representaba el sector oficial obtuvo el
60 por ciento de los votos
113 se expresó en 114 puestos de 167
escaños en el parlamento y luego de eso
vino vinieron las leyes del poder
comunal fue el período legislativo es el
que más leyes habilitantes se aprobaron
se reformó la ley orgánica del tribunal
supremo de justicia para aumentar la
cantidad de magistrados se dictó una
nueva ley electoral y se designó un
nuevo consejo nacional electoral el reto
que tiene el sector oficial en este
momento es autorregularse podrá hacerlo
lo veo difícil porque su vocación ha
sido siempre hegemónica
y lo digo con el mayor de los respetos
porque además es la vocación hegemónica
no es exclusiva del chavismo en este
continente así lo vimos con el pri en
mexico
y lo hemos visto con el peronismo en
argentina
lamentablemente el mismo accionar del
sector oficial ha prácticamente
eliminado sus opciones de
y contrapartes tienen una oposición que
está mucho más interesada en complacer a
la comunidad internacional y los
lineamientos que recibe de algunos
actores de la comunidad internacional y
tiene una oposición que ha decidido
participar en la elección pero que no
tiene arrastre popular llevar adelante
un diálogo sin contrapartes es bastante
complejo además se va a complejizar
muchísimo más cualquier tipo de
acercamiento de negociación de diálogo
por la cantidad de iteraciones que van a
ocurrir tomando en cuenta que cada vez
hay más actores en el sector oposición
asamblea nacional que se ha resultado
electa tendrá el reto de designar un
nuevo consejo nacional electoral
designar a unos magistrados cuyo periodo
está vencido designaron fiscal general y
designar a un contralor general frente a
esto hay cada vez más actores del sector
oposición
y esa es otra de las de las
tareas que tendrá que tomar en cuenta el
sector oficial para poder plantear una
negociación seria que sea reconocida
además por quienes por ejemplo han
venido apoyando el diálogo en venezuela
cómo es el reino de noruega si amy y
precisamente ya que usted habla de la
comunidad internacional y por ejemplo la
forma en que ha estado participando el
reino de noruega tratando de acercar a
ambas partes para instaurar una mesa de
diálogo como cree usted que la comunidad
internacional puede reaccionar a partir
del 5 de enero puede haber entonces más
presión sobre nicolás maduro más
sanciones internacionales porque la
unión europea de entrada ya dijo que no
va a reconocer estos comicios a eeuu se
mantiene en esta posición pero pues hay
un cambio de gobierno ya veremos qué
puede pasar con la nueva administración
y los países vecinos también se
mantienen en esta misma línea que cree
usted que puede suceder proveniendo de
la comunidad internacional bueno yo
esperaría que la comunidad internacional
tome nota de lo que ha ocurrido en los
últimos dos años
que venezuela está mucho más cerca de
una solución cuesta más lejos
si la comunidad internacional continúa
sin tomar en cuenta los resultados que
se han obtenido hasta ahora debería
evaluar incluso escenarios de
cronificación como el caso de siria
u otros países en donde las crisis
políticas se estancan y
independientemente de las decisiones de
parte de la comunidad internacional
porque en algo en coincidir con sus
iguales diferenciar a los países de la
comunidad internacional si bien es
cierto que tanto la unión europea como
eeuu han planteado grandes presiones
sobre el gobierno de nicolás maduro
también tampoco puede negarse que recibe
un gran apoyo de otros países como
turquía china rusia que no pueden así
pero me refería quizás al músculo al
músculo financiero y este este gobierno
camina hacia encontrar un punto de
equilibrio a través de la ley anti
bloqueo
y estabilizar la precariedad en cierto
sentido por lo cual que yo creo que la
comunidad internacional debería revisar
detenidamente cuáles son los éxitos y
los fracasos y recordar que la decisión
del conflicto venezolano debe estar en
manos de los venezolanos y la absolución
que debamos construir tiene que pasar
necesariamente
por nuestras manos nuestra idiosincrasia
y nuestra forma de resolver los
conflictos claro jesús y cuál es su
opinión al respecto sobre la forma en
que la comunidad internacional puede
comenzar a actuar a presionar más a
nicolás maduró simplemente se hará el de
la vista gorda y deja que las cosas
fluyan o como dice amy pueda empezar a
ver de pronto un cambio en la mirada por
parte de la comunidad internacional y se
empieza a ver a venezuela de otra manera
y simplemente pues estos países que
apoyan al gobierno de nicolás maduro
empiecen a ejercer ahí alguna presión en
actores como eeuu la unión europea los
países de américa latina como lo vio
usted
voy a ser enfático eeuu no es la
comunidad internacional los 28 países de
la unión europea no son la comunidad
internacional ellos son una alianza que
tiene una posición política y que
respeta la soberanía de venezuela de
otros países que tienen un
funcionamiento interno distinto a los
dictados de eeuu tenemos la capacidad de
sobrevivir en venezuela a pesar del
propio criminal
eeuu del robo descarado de nuestros
recursos de nuestras carteleras de
nuestras reservas de oro tenemos la
capacidad económica tenemos los aliados
para hacerlo tenemos a china tenemos a
irán tenemos una variedad de aliados en
américa latina también tenemos pues que
haremos frente a esto porque lo que está
planteado de parte de eeuu es por la vía
del bloqueo criminal asfixiar
económicamente al país y que de alguna
forma el presidente es renuncia el
presidente maduro y eso no está
contemplado en la carta de la oea no
está contemplado del derecho
internacional es un acto realmente
criminal que tiene circunstancias
agravantes
porque estamos en tiempos de coronavirus
de pandemia donde la ayuda humanitaria
debería prevalecer no las agendas
políticas todos los bloqueos criminales
que hay contra venezuela y otros países
del mundo deberían suspenderse para
darle prioridad a lo humanitario
yo creo que esta política es rara de
eeuu y que lamentablemente lo europeo no
tiene criterio propio sino que obedece a
los de washington es lo que el pueblo de
estados unidos castigó severamente a
través de esa derrota electoral
aparatosa que sufrió el señor donald
trump entonces tenemos reservas
económicas y políticas en venezuela para
sobrevivir este bloqueo y confío en que
están los tempranos dentro del propio
eeuu se va a generar una presión
política del pueblo de eeuu para el cese
de este bloqueo absurdo en tradicional
contra el jugador a 50 años y tampoco va
a funcionar contra venezuela la
oposición democrática de venezuela tiene
un espacio garantizado del parlamento
obtuvo un millón de votos
no se le puede menospreciar y ella podrá
en este parlamento exponer sus puntos de
vida y venezuela va a seguir teniendo
una vida democrática con libertades y
con derecho constitucional como la hemos
llevado durante estos 20 años más allá
de los aparatos de propaganda que
presentan a venezuela como dictadura a
estado fallido en venezuela las
elecciones son libres en eeuu están
siendo cuestionadas por el propio
presidente de ese país de modo pues que
venezuela puede darle lecciones de
electoral eeuu y no a la inmensa jesús'
el 5 de enero ya lo decíamos finaliza
este periodo legislativo de esta
asamblea nacional pese a que el gobierno
creó una asamblea paralela para para
llevar a cabo algunos de los planes de
gobierno que tenía en mente y finaliza
el periodo legislativo de juan guaidó el
termina deja de ser el presidente de la
asamblea también se acaba la inmunidad
que cree que va a pasar con él usted
cree que el gobierno de nicolás maduro
va a tomar cartas en el asunto con el
tema juan guaidó
te digo rápidamente como doctor en
derecho constitucional no hay una
asamblea paralela en venezuela se eligió
por voto popular una asamblea
constituyente que cumplió una labor y
que seguramente va a terminar su periodo
y en lo que respecta a juan guaidó es
una
el poder judicial de los jueces
venezolanos decidir cuáles son los
procedimientos legales que deben
aplicarse en este caso no es una
decisión de nicolás maduro nicolás
maduro ejerciendo la presidencia nunca
ha dictado ningún tipo de sentencia
judicial
venezuela tiene independencia de poderes
y yo confío en que los jueces
venezolanos aplicaran sus criterios
el señor guaidó está implicado en el
robo de circo estamos hablando de más de
40 mil millones de dólares el sirvió
como fachada para que eeuu nos robaran
nuestra principal industria petrolera en
el exterior eso ha ocasionado penurias
económicas para el pueblo venezolano y
alguien tiene que poner crímenes graves
que puede costar decenas de miles de
vidas
el señor bueno participó en el robo de
monómeros una rama de la industria
petrolera que está en colombia en el
país donde ustedes en este momento están
físicamente cuando tienen que responder
ante la justicia venezolana pero repito
no es decisión del presidente nicolás
maduro
es decisión de los jueces venezolanos
amy su opinión sobre que va a ser el
futuro de juan guaidó una vez termine su
legislatura el 5 de enero del 2021 y se
acaba también su inmunidad
bueno mira una pregunta difícil jugar a
ser astrólogo sobre el futuro agua yo
creo que cualquier político desea y
aspira mantener
al menos una baja una baja un bajo nivel
de rechazo no es el caso de guayo creo
que además es su primera pérdida gran
pérdida haber dilapidado el capital
político que en algún momento obtuvo
con respecto a si el gobierno de nicolás
maduro va a proceder
tomar alguna medida en contra de él creo
que hasta ahora hasta ahora el gobierno
ha actuado con más mesura de la que se
cree
también hay que recordar que cuando
hablamos del gobierno con las maduro no
estamos hablando de una sola ala sino
que son varias alas disfrutándose
liderazgo y disputándose incluso la
posibilidad de quién será el que releve
maduro en el 2024
también pesa creo la necesidad de que se
obtenga el reconocimiento de esa nueva
asamblea nacional pareciera
y lógico que el gobierno de maduro vaya
a tomar una decisión que empañe al menos
la primera quincena de enero tomando en
cuenta que el 5 de enero se instala la
nueva asamblea nacional y que el 10 de
enero debería nicolás maduró asistir a
esa asamblea nacional a rendir
cuenta el informe anual de la nación
sin embargo no descartó que sectores
duros de el gobierno pues
decidan y presionen para su aprehensión
y esto podría desencadenar también en un
en otra coyuntura política aún más aguda
allí en venezuela y mis hijos con usted
este plan que presentó wide o con el que
cautivo en algún momento a la comunidad
internacional y que fue comprado como ya
lo dijimos por varios países que lo
apoyaron este plan de ss la usurpación
un gobierno de transición elecciones
libres y también un poco ayudado desde
colombia de eeuu con una estrategia de
un cerco diplomático hacia venezuela
esto falló
evidente que todavía está en miraflores
yo creo que además está descartado
cotino en una siguiente fase entonces
bueno yo creo que si lo hubiese hubiese
entendido que el fracaso hubiese puesto
que hubiese aprovechado la coyuntura
para entregar a la directiva de la
asamblea nacional cosa que no hizo
creo que además la parte de la comunidad
internacional apoyó una política que
jamás hubiese apoyado dentro de sus
países y se encuentra en cierto modo
entrampada porque tendría que desdecirse
de dos años de respaldo absoluto a una
[Música]
un mantra un eslogan publicitario que y
detrás de eso que lo que en el momento
de mayor presión estoy hablando de
quizás el 23 de febrero del 2000
y los días subsiguientes no se utilizó
para acudir a una mesa de negociación y
tratar de resolver
la capacidad de movilización popular
está absolutamente devastada
y el rechazo que hay hacia los partidos
políticos el rechazo que haya sea la
dirigencia de los partidos políticos es
innegable
lo que mejor le podría servir a la
oposición en este momento es que la
dirigencia a quienes han dado la cara o
quienes han servido de vanguardia asuman
ante el país su rechazo y permitan que
una nueva oposición comience a trabajar
sobre las bases del realismo y de tratar
de hacer política además tendrán eso sí
van a tener que enfrentarse a una gran
paradoja no mientras mayor fortaleza
tenga la oposición en lo político muy
probable que tenga menores condiciones y
menores incentivos para acudir a una
cita electoral
e históricamente es importante señalar
lo siguiente en venezuela- ninguna
oposición que ha intentado tomar el
poder a través de invasiones lo ha
logrado
preguntar desde la perspectiva fuera de
venezuela fuera de las fronteras de
venezuela
hay muchos rumores se comenta mucho se
ve también en la prensa tanto venezolana
como internacional que hay ciertas
fracturas al interior del chavismo y que
hay ciertas divisiones y pujas de poder
al interior de esta conformación que
lleva el chavismo a través del partido
socialista unido de venezuela pero ahora
pues en estas elecciones donde
resultaron con la mayoría de los escaños
en esta nueva asamblea nacional pues uno
notaría a un cierto fortalecimiento que
tan fortalecido está el chavismo después
de estos comicios
[Aplausos]
las
rumores de la prensa tenemos que
basarnos en los hechos y acciones el
partido socialista unido de venezuela
obtenido más del 68 por ciento de los
votos para la asamblea nacional se ha
presentado como una variedad de aliados
la votación ha sido contundente el
índice de participación se asemeja a
otros países de la región e inclusive de
lo que se denomina el primer mundo esto
es una demostración de fuerza política
de unidad la preocupación debe
encontrarse en la oposición donde han
bajado millones de votos han perdido
millones de votos donde quien por
reconocido como supuesto líder de la
oposición por un grupo de países que no
son largos
internacional porque la comunidad
internacional unión europea novela
internacional bueno están apostando
estos países a un señor que está
políticamente derrotado en venezuela que
es rechazado por la inmensa mayoría de
los venezolanos que le cuestionan el
robo de empresas pertenecientes a la
industria venezolana son cual ha traído
enorme catástrofe económica para el
entonces el que tenga ojos que vea hay
que reconocer las fuerzas del chavismo
que ha sido demostrada en estas
elecciones estamos en un país bloqueado
donde el 99 por ciento del ingreso en
dólares que generaba la industria
petrolera venezolana ha decaído producto
un bloqueo criminal yo estoy diciendo
que en venezuela el gobierno sea
perfecto y no tenga fallas las tiene
pero no se puede ocultar
y desconocer este bloqueo criminal
estados unidos afectados severamente
a pesar de esta crisis tan tremenda que
padecemos el gobierno el sector chavista
se ha visto fortalecido
una avalancha de sus significativas que
no se aprovechó también para preguntarle
qué lecturas y ustedes de esa
participación del 31 por ciento del
padrón electoral son 40 puntos
porcentuales por debajo de las
parlamentarias del 2015 independiente de
oposición chavismo
es el voto de los venezolanos que le
dice usted está alta abstención
creo que es una abstención que acontece
en una situación típica para el mundo
estamos viviendo la pandemia de el
coronavirus
en tiempos de cuarentena no se puede
comparar esta situación especial con
ninguna situación anterior y a pesar de
eso hay que observar qué
las fuerzas del chavismo obtienen más de
4 millones de votos entonces ese
porcentaje creo que es significativo que
es respetable que es una base política
importante y que ahora el gobierno y el
chavismo en el parlamento deben trabajar
día y noche por pelear legalmente contra
el bloqueo contra el robo de los bienes
venezolanos porque la derrota de ese
bloqueo ilegal de esas confiscaciones
ilegales serán determinantes para la
recuperación económica de venezuela
ojalá en este mundo desarrollado esta
gente que no son la comunidad
internacional y que son simplemente eeuu
y sus aliados
haya reflexión sobre esta política
errada sobre esta política de odio la
política de intolerancia y levanten las
sanciones de lo que yo quiero pedirle el
presidente de eeuu
electos white que por favor reflexiones
sobre el bloqueo levante la sanción y
jesús y que no repite el faltas
donald trump
exterior realmente es un desastre amy y
su lectura de esta alta abstención en
venezuela en estos comicios cuál es la
lectura que usted hace que el mensaje
está mandando allí los venezolanos a
través de esa falta de salir a ejercer
su derecho ciudadano mire yo creo que
ante una altísima abstención todos somos
perdedores
en primer lugar
señal de una falta de confianza en el
proceso más allá de la discusión acerca
de si fueron unas elecciones legítimas y
fueron competitivas o no
una falta de participación y una apatía
debe preocuparnos a todos
la salud de una democracia no sólo puede
evidentemente medirse por la cantidad de
votos ahora que los candidatos no sean
ni él ni los candidatos ni el proceso
sean suficientes para estimular la
participación creo que es una grave
llamada de atención para todos los
actores políticos para quienes
decidieron a través de una decisión
política implementar la lista nacional
modificar el voto indígena convocar la
elección sin un cronograma para quienes
hicieron campaña por la abstención y
éste sigue digamos en sintonía con esa
ruta de la que algún soldado
norteamericano iba a descender de un
helicóptero y sido diagrama duro y
también es un llamado para quienes
siendo opositores llamando al voto no
lograron superar más de 2 millones por
supuesto que esa cifra está
por la migración que creo que en
colombia están bastante informados sobre
ese tema que por la crisis del
combustible y hay otros otros elementos
como por ejemplo el tema de coronavirus
sin duda pero la salud del sistema
electoral debe preocuparnos a todos
mucho más cuando los próximos tres años
vamos a estar acudiendo a procesos
electorales y será muy difícil para
quienes no participaron en esta elección
aludiendo a la falta de condiciones
intenten ahora postularse para la
próxima elección que será en menos de
deberíamos estar viendo elecciones en
diciembre del próximo año noviembre o
diciembre el próximo año entonces creo
que este
es muy muy preocupante el tema de la
extensión y debería ser además una
preocupación de todos más allá del
discurso de que si el chavismo logró los
millones de votos o 5 millones de votos
tenemos un problema tenemos un problema
y debemos como sociedad resolverlo pues
con esa reflexión
amy llegamos al final de este debate
aquí en france24 y agradezco a amy nogal
ya jesús silva desde la ciudad de
caracas por haber estado con nosotros y
habernos expresado sus diferentes puntos
de vista en torno al futuro de la
oposición y también sus reflexiones
sobre este proceso electoral que tuvo
venezuela este fin de semana que recién
terminó ustedes muchas gracias por haber
estado con nosotros pueden seguir
dejando todos sus comentarios y sus
preguntas a través de las redes sociales
los invito para que sigan entonces con
la programación de france 24 siga con
nosotros buenas noches
[Música]